inside Channing and Jenna Dewan Tatum
marriage what went wrong and why Kaley
Cuoco is getting real about her first
marriage to Ryan Sweeting Plus Demi
Lovato and Kalani packed on some heavy
PDA on stage hey guys i'm danny direct
oh and love is dead you know it's so sad
as I think I've said that so many times
on this show but yes another celeb
couple bites the dust after eight years
of marriage Channing Tatum and Jenna
Dewan announced it is over Chani and
Jenna broke the news in a joint
statement posted on Instagram they wrote
we have lovingly chosen to separate
adding there are no secrets nor
salacious events at the root of our
decision so what sparked the break-up
while ET spoke to multiple sources close
to the couple who tell us their split
has been brewing for a wild quote they
have been fighting the last couple of
years quite a bit we're told they tried
couples therapy but now with the
announcement there's a sense of relief
on both of their parts and Channing
finally doesn't have to hide that he was
ready to move on now we did some digging
and maybe the signs were there all along
their last red carpet appearance
together was way back in November last
year for wardog a month later the couple
jetted off to Cabo to celebrate her 37th
birthday
then in March Jenna hits several events
without Channing including the Vanity
Fair Oscar party honey babysitting is a
tiny duty tonight
I took his place the two also arrived
separately to the Kids Choice Awards
where Jenna brought their four and a
half year old daughter Everly
all right so I want to know from you
guys are you shook by the split or did
you see it come in
are you watching step up to cope let's
find strength in numbers people I mean
while Kate Lee cuoco will soon walk down
the aisle for the second time when she
went Karl cook but it's her first
husband that's got the Big Bang Theory
star holding nothing back Kaylie looking
lovely on the cover of cosmos may issue
tells the Mack she never thought she
would get married again and that her
ex-husband Ryan Sweeting ruined the word
for her the two got engaged in September
2013 after three months of dating tied
the knot three months later only two
announced they were separating in
September 2015
Kaylie says it was all his doing quote I
married someone the first time who
completely changed the person I ended up
with was not the person I originally met
I had to go through a lot of things but
it brought me to Carl now this this is
true Kaylie is truly smitten as et found
out just a few weeks before Carl popped
the question you know we have this
special bond and yeah the animals and he
he's as real he's so real I've never met
a kinder human being he's gentle and
he's real and I'm completely in love
with him nothing could be better moving
on to a different duo who I am ready to
ship ASAP
Demi Lovato and Kalani the two singers
sizzled on stage last night and sealed
their last tour stuck together with a
seductive kiss it all went down Monday
night in Newark New Jersey during the
last u.s. stop on Demi's tell me you
love me tour Kalani is the opening act
and both singers left quite an
impression during their final show
together
the crowd screaming and I am screaming
over that too like they totally went for
it and Kalani wrote on Instagram that
Denny's dancers encouraged her to
surprise Demi on stage during lonely
obviously it's a super sexy number and
things got steamy
after the sexy show both singers took to
social media
Kalani gushed anyone would be stupid not
to jump at the chance to hop on that Dan
moving bed and grab your face while Demi
wrote what an incredible fun sexy crazy
night that I'll never forget
clearly the tell me you love me tour has
been everything she told et it would be
when we talk to her back in March we
wanted to showcase all aspects of my
self as an artist playing guitar playing
piano you know just thank you and also
showing us exercise but also being
vulnerable and open with uh with
audience well listen congrats on a good
run Demi but what a closer you guys hit
me up in the comments section if you
were there I want to hear all about it
and as always you guys can catch these
stories and a whole lot more over at et
online.com slash daily Denney and be
sure to hit subscribe we'll be back with
another daily Deni win you guessed it
tomorrow
[Music]